[Music]
well finale of this is us just ended
what a tearjerker
how could I be this sad I never even met
the baby never held him or her hates
miscarriage story has been so
heartbreaking but has resonated with so
many people I love that she's going to
try again
her and Toby what can you tell us about
that journey and where that story line
is gonna take us yeah you know I think
that what's so beautiful about what the
writers decided to do was that there's
this huge life event that changes you
forever but it's not going to break
their relationship and that's so vital
to a healthy relationship and also like
while you get into your year future
relationship and while she said yeah
we're gonna try again just not right
away you know it's it was so symbolic
that they put up that shower curtain
together that they're gonna get through
it together baby sobs right it's just
really grateful that we've like
approached these subjects that are
literally bringing strangers in
literally in bathrooms with me like we
cry and we talk about these life events
and women who've reached out to me via
social media and I'm like oh my gosh
this is why we do this art you wish to
adopt this child as your legally adopted
son we do do I feel like so much of
Randall's storyline is focused on
fostering and adoption could that be an
avenue that Kate and Toby explore sure
you know why not you know if if for some
reason they aren't able to physically
have a child then why not and because it
obviously was so wonderful and
beneficial and advantageous for Randall
and for the Cole family that yeah why
not I think Toby cater they want to love
you know and extend their love whether
its adoptive or a biological child so
yeah how are you and Josh spending the
holidays together he's coming home with
me to Florida so that's gonna be fun and
you know we've done it last year so he's
he's brace for impact or you know he's
he's gonna handle it yeah he'll be all
right but yeah we're excited just to
kind of just chill out
lots of love with your cast Mandy got
engaged Justin just got married what are
the chances that you got engaged in 2018
oh girl pop the brakes nobody is trying
to get married I can of course have a
healthy relationship but I'm not in any
rush to kind of get married